[Applause]
simon thank you very much
can i dive can i die everybody
as i just said to the uh uh the nice
person from the bbc which i thought was
the right way to address her uh
great to see you listen and by the way i
am very very proud that uh the new
director of communications in
in number 10 speaks fluent welsh votes
the biggest the biggest takeover of
welsh takeover win in number 10 since in
westminster i should say since the
tudors anyway uh great to be here in
paris what absolutely beautiful place
beautiful uh a beautiful beautiful park
why did god spend lockdown in wales
he was working from home
now look i want you to i want you to
cast your mind backwards if you can
almost uh uh almost half a century uh uh
to um
to 1974. now look i'm looking down
there's
this rose of young thrusters here you
don't uh you you don't remember 1974. uh
but but i i do ever had a number one hit
called waterloo uh gareth edwards was
the welsh uh scrum half i was banging
boinging around on a space hopper at the
age of 10
but i'm proud to say that you have to go
all the way back to 1974
to find a time when unemployment was as
low in the uk as it is today
and whatever the difficulties that the
post coded economy faces now i just want
you to dwell on that for a second and
remember that months ago forecasters
were saying that the pandemic would put
millions and millions of people out of
work and i had them into number 10. i
didn't they're out of work uh i said uh
they said uh unemployment would be
running
between 12 and 14
it's now down to 3.7
and which as i say is a a
lot it's been uh since 1974. and that is
because i think we got the big calls
right during kobed and this conservative
government is getting on with taking the
big decisions the tough decisions and
the right decisions to take this country
forward at home and abroad the welsh
people apart from everybody else asked
us to deliver brexit and we did
the british people asked to be protected
from kobit and we rolled out vaccines
faster than any other european country
the ukrainian people needed our help to
protect them against the vicious
aggression of vladimir putin and we were
the first european country to send those
heroic ukrainians the assistance they
needed
[Applause]
and and they have been incredible they
have repelled putin from the gates of
kiev
and just as we got the most difficult
challenges uh of kovid writing got the
big calls right we will get this country
through the big uh change the big
challenges now and the post covered
aftershocks the pressures are caused in
particular by the rise in the cost of
living
everybody can see what's happening the
cost at
fuel pumps uh the price of food cost of
energy we all know how tough
it is
and how tough it can be
and
as with covid
we see the same waves
the same problems
around the world in america in
in europe in australia
and we can see the causes
as clear as day
first the disruption in supply chains
and the sudden demand for oil and gas as
the global economy came out of covid and
then a new surge in prices caused by
putin's aggression
the surge in the price of oil and gas
now as the world struggles to end its
addiction to russian hydrocarbons the
surge in the price of food
25 million tons
of grain
grain the world desperately needs
still locked up in silos in odessa
because the black sea is now littered
with mines
and of course we're going to get through
this and the the markets will eventually
adjust and new supply will come on
and prices will come down again and
in the months ahead we are going to have
to do what we did before
we're going to use our fiscal firepower
that we built up uh that we have uh to
help
we're going to put our arms
around the british people again as we
did during covet and never forget
there's only one reason
why we were able to
produce to afford furlough
and all the 400 billion pounds worth of
support and that was because we
conservatives had managed the economy
sensibly and responsibly
and there's only one reason now why our
economy is strong enough
to continue to help and that is because
we took the tough decisions and got the
big calls right when by the way labor
was telling us to stay in lockdown
and mark drakeford i think actually
criminalized people for going into the
office didn't he
neighbours
tells you all you need to know uh
remember captain hindsight telling us it
was reckless to open up the economy in
july last year well we ignored him
and weren't we right
just as we ignored him over ignored
labor over a christmas and a new year
and that's why because we took those
tough decisions youth unemployment is at
or near a record low we have half a
million more people in payroll
employment than before the pandemic and
our economy is now bigger than before
covid and at the same time
as we use our economic strength that
we've built up
to help people through the postcovid
aftershocks
we're going to do the necessary thing
we're going to fix the underlying
problems
just as we did with kobe remember
while labor
vacillated we vaccinated
and let me ask you
where was that oh who was asked who was
vaccinated with astrazeneca by the way
fantastic
good for you so was i uh
let me ask you where that precious fluid
was bottled
close
who said macclesfield graham
mackelsfield is only partly right
millions and millions of doses were
produced in wales
in wrexham in wrexham by the way that is
now represented by a conservative mp for
the first time not in a generation but
for the first time since 1935
wrexham that now has a state-of-the-art
vaccine manufacturing plant uh wok heart
because they're called because then the
the motto of the family is walk heart
they believe in heart in heart walk
if that would have been unimaginable uh
25 years ago when i uh first campaigned
in the in the adjacent in the adjacent
scene by the way that seat 2
now has a conservative member of
parliament and
the same wrexham the same wrexham uh
that today i think we can announce or
maybe it was yesterday i can't remember
her majesty has now accorded the status
of a city for her jubilee year and wales
wales will be at the heart of our
mission now to fix the underlying issues
in our energy market all the things that
our previous governments have failed to
address wales with its boundless
potential for clean energy of every kind
we're massively accelerating our program
of offshore wind and uh particularly off
the coast of south wales we're putting
in now we've announced today another 160
million pounds worth of investment into
port facilities that will enable the
companies to come and uh install and
build uh the turbines that we need so
that we can take our offshore wind
capacity i mean we're already the saudi
arabia of wind but we'll take it uh from
11 gigawatts now to 50 gigawatts of wind
uh by 2030. now that's that's 50
gigawatts from offshore wind that's half
the total electricity consumption of the
uk
and wales with its nuclear heritage and
potential squandered under labour which
we're now reviving
with a new reactor every year rather
than every decade
not just in wilford i i can think i can
see atomic kitten
they're there in the front row uh but
today i can tell you that we're looking
to build another small modular reactor
on the site at transfinith
did simon say that already
[Applause]
i think it's fantastic news
and that is how it's by investing in
nuclear by the way 50 gigawatts what
gigawatts bottle in 25 gigawatts of
nuclear that's how we will make sure
that we have the base load not just for
uh british households for people who are
feeling the pinch make sure we don't
have this problem again but for our
industry for our businesses from welsh
steel to the wealth welsh aircraft uh
manufacturing that makes half the wings
of all the passenger jets in the world i
think i think i think simon may well
have said that but it's worth saying uh
again uh to the electric heaters warming
the
lambing sheds of wells they probably
they'd probably stop warming landing
shows and wells now but they still uh
agriculture needs uh energy welsh
business uh needs energy and we will
provide uh and the whole problem not
just wales but the whole country uh with
long long term uh low
carbon secure
and dependable supply
and
the the reason we're going ahead at this
scale and this pace is that as i say
this government takes the big decisions
the tough decisions that have been
shirked for a generation and never
forget
the reason why we're in the position we
are is because it was a labor
party in 1997 before their 13 years in
power who said there was no case no
economic case for more nuclear power
with a characteristic prescience
remind them of that every time they
complain about energy shortages energy
prices in our country my friends let us
get on with the job uniting and leveling
up across wells and across the whole
country with investment in roads and
rail across the north of wales
throughout the uh throughout the country
gigabit broadband i think i heard simon
mentioned that gigabit broadband which
is of such value to uh communities
particularly rote and remote uh rural
communities
those infrastructure investments are
helping to drive jobs and growth across
the economy it is it is a massive and
exciting agenda for change
infrastructure skills
technology that is how we are going to
transform our country and make it fit
for the future can i just ask you do you
do you think at this juncture
when putin
is muttering recklessly about
using his nuclear arsenal
do we really want our defense policy
handed over
to a bunch of
semi-repentant corbyn easter loons to
put it marv
eight never forget eight of the shadow
front bench
including the shadow foreign secretary
voted to scrap this country's
independent nuclear deterrent is that
the right thing for our country now is
that the right thing for nato now is
that the right thing for the world for
ukraine absolutely not